hello freak bitches Buddhism is a
religion I mean at least in terms of how
we understand religion is it tax free is
it tax free yeah do you have a tax-free
exemption the same way that other
religions do we personally don't but you
don't you could you could do that yeah
you'll get fucking chased down don't do
it really hairy when you don't want to
pay taxes they go oh really time to take
a little closer look at the Buddhist
geek organization yeah see what you're
doing on Saturday that's their
infiltrate yeah I think I mean you
inherit but using that framework we
inherit all you know we Herod it and so
there's a lot about religions and
spirituality in general that is not that
I don't personally like you know like
what so I think that there is a there's
a tendency to project I mean you brought
in the word divinity so I'll use that
like to project our divinity on to the
teachers are on to some sort of system
and it can be disempowering for a lot of
people people can get trapped in beliefs
that you know have been carried forward
for you know years and centuries that
aren't isn't forwarding anymore and so
that sense like by choosing to go under
Buddhism we're also choosing to you know
work on how we can evolve how we think
about it and one thing that I really
like is the is the practices themselves
the mind training aspect of it that's
what's been really beneficial to me and
that's one of the reasons when I've
chosen to continue because if its impact
the mind training aspects of it like
what what do you think is like the
tangible benefits of this mind training
aspect of it that you personally
experience personally I can say
personally I feel much much more much
more open and much more generous
compassionate there's a lot more freedom
I can get stuck on the smaller sense of
self meaning you know I have these
thoughts of like unworthiness or self
contraction or hatred or any of those
you know biological kind of urges and
at the same time they're so transient
and they're so not who I am and I see
that very very clearly that it kind of
diminishes in just a second on the good
days sometimes it's more intense and
I've learned to really work with that
and learn how to see clearly what's
happening so that I have the freedom to
really choose how to live my life in a
much more full way that just the
evidence that the Internet is real that
is one of the best evidence is that
there are people that are just so far
beyond how fucking smart you think smart
is it's like remember when you were like
five or six years old you had like a lot
of times you had like there's one kid in
the neighborhood that maybe it was like
a little bit bigger a little bit
stronger than other kids and when you
would play with them on the field like
you get like bummed out like you get
knocked over and shit like remember what
you thought that was like that was a
strong little kid but if you were there
right now you'd be like get out of here
you little fuck stop knocking in
everybody you know I mean I it was a
more secured that he had freckles or
something like yeah you'd be like get
out he fucking little weirdo don't be
mean to me I'm a grown-ass man but
that's what I feel like
like technologically and in just the the
the mental capacity of a super genius in
comparison to me I feel like if I'm that
little kid and like if I tried to figure
out how the fuck they figured out the
Internet I'd just be like oh my brain
isn't worked out good I can't talk to
you
you're freaking me out man you know if
you if you went into one of those dudes
offices and they had of those crazy like
Good Will Hunting shit on the wall and
he's doing those equations that fucking
nobody understands yeah you know that
they'll work on for years you know even
if professor didn't yeah how did you
yeah I remember like in Good Will
Hunting the fucking the janitor fixes
the problem they leave it open to the
janitor can work on the problem really
yeah what if you just erased it what if
he's just crazy yeah he's not why you a
janitor bitch this is a stupid story
you're a super genius janitor get the
fuck out of here the fuck out here
you're smarter than anybody you can
figure out these equations and nobody
else
Chanin you're also beautiful right what
are the yard and charming what are we uh
it's just so wacky that's so wacky so I
see we could spend the whole thing
talking about this because it's so it's
one of those things where like there's a
bunch of people in on a joke mm-hmm
you know and you're like just wanting
someone to say okay we're just fucking
them well those belief systems the thing
about having those belief systems is
that they're very empowering for people
who believe in them like if you if you
look at it and go wait a minute wait a
minute fucking planet Xenu really yeah I
know it's insane like I'm reading about
this after you brought up X Cal for what
you're talking about and I pulled up
that website that mock Scientology Xenu
net oh I've never been there but this oh
my favorite site bro they have
everything they have they have the
entire Scientology like like everything
about what they believe all of the
operating yeah man you know I got that
WikiLeaks operating the operating manual
like level 3 which is apparently where I
guess Tom Cruise is like four or five or
six or something but he was three couple
years like they have different manuals
you know so he was three a couple years
ago now he's four or five or six I don't
know where he said I haven't keeping up
with his level what rank he's at but I
know he's ranked up because they've like
given him they made up some new award
for him and did you ever see that video
that leaked yeah he's like using all the
stuff that was like they made up this
one they made up this thing they'd never
had before as a guardian of the galaxy I
gave it to him and he was like he's like
saying all that chin it made no sense
even on their words and stuff yeah like
the internet and people put music to it
and she had gorgeous yeah it's so good
to work of art it is it is man I mean
almost it is almost like like something
that you would see from some artists
who's doing so I'm like fucking peace
yeah where he's gay man that'd be so
brilliant if like he just all of a
sudden flipped and told everybody yeah
I've been just listen it helps my acting
if I could pretend to really be into
Scientology this long it's like the Dumb
and Dumber may the new one coming out
have you seen the preview I have oh my
god it's genius but there's like there's
the old thing where Jim Carrey
characters care
Carrie's character is like in a insane
asylum go over this over that chick the
merry Samsonite is it known from the
first one and then it turns out he was
like joking like for like 20 years and
Lloyd Lloyd you mean to tell me that
you've been even faking for twenty years
all for a gag and he's like yep be
amazing if you did that